i love to to you know to take uh things
apart like like a like a broken
television set and build something out
of it um so i was always i like to call
it i was always a creator i always
always love to invent things
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm joined
today by aviv shapira the co-founder and
ceo of extend
aviva is an aerospace engineer and holds
two emmy awards for the best
broadcasting technology of 2013 and
2015. he co-founded replay technologies
which invented a new volumetric video
format that has been used at major
sports events around the world
after winning two emmy awards the replay
was acquired by intel in 2016. today he
is the ceo of extend in the field of
extended reality which aims to give
people the ability to fly through an
immersive experience using vr and drones
aviv shapira welcome to 20 minute
leaders from extend how are you i'm
doing great what's up
thank you so much for being here you're
working on some of the most cool some of
the coolest technologies there are
looking at the extended ability of
humans to do things that we weren't we
weren't able to do before your
entrepreneurial experience began from
the age of 10 where you're running
different businesses you managed along
the way to sell your company replay to
intel one i believe two emmy awards you
broke a satellite and now you're
continuing to work on some pretty crazy
technologies so thank you for taking
time out of your busy schedule to be
here did i capture just a little bit of
what you've done yeah as you mentioned
life is not boring at all it's very
interesting
that's what it sounds like right now
keep it real before we go back your
journey and i want to hear all about
breaking satellites and being a 10 year
old entrepreneur extend give me a few
words about extend and how you're
looking at the extended and the
extensive reality that we're that we
might be living in the future
so basically uh as we see the future
with everything going on with kovid and
everything all going on with the
internet you know the whole world
getting smaller and more accessible
we think that
that humans will be able in the future
to actually interact with remote
realities
with a machine so you don't have to go
anywhere physically you can do things
remotely and what extent is trying to do
is actually create that that interface
between humans and machine actually
allowing us
as humans to interact in the most
immersive way possible in in real time
uh with
endless uh um applications uh um you
know for endless markets from remote is
from security allowing basically
security personnel to do things from
remote uh virtual sightseeing virtual
gaming
basically anything that you want that
you can do from from your sofa from your
home
we're gonna allow you to do that uh uh
in the most effective way possible it
reminds me a little bit of the wall-e
movie where you have people just sitting
back and just enjoying the world but but
but it was a pretty bad depiction of
where humanity can go paint me a picture
of where humanity can go with these
sorts of technologies and experiencing
what what is made possible
that will benefit humanity and society
that is not made possible today with our
limitations of just being human
i mean the first thing that we're trying
to do is actually make an impact so
why risk yourself as a police officer or
as a fireman going into a burning
building yourself with a suit if you can
do it from remote uh you know you see
you're sitting in your truck you put vr
in your head and you're flying into a
burning building you know you're finding
survivors you're you're giving them a
bottle of water you try to extinguish
the the fire itself and everything is
done uh using our technology so man
machine interface um
that's that's the core i mean
you know above that yeah you can have
fun you can you can go and see the
safari in in south africa you can go and
and see uh waves in puerto rico
uh but the core of the technology
actually allows you to interact uh with
a remote machine and actually make you
feel like you're like you're there
incredible incredible and obviously you
know there's dozens of applications
whether it be life-saving applications
experiential applications but i want you
to take me back to 10 years old
entrepreneurial experience and what i'd
love to understand from these different
experiences that you've had what what
are you drawing to today's to your work
today whether it be you know from the
different ventures you've built to
replay to breaking a satellite
uh
you're asking what's what's what's the
what's in the middle what makes it it
all happen what's the core i want to
hear i want to hear a little bit about
your journey and then from those
experiences from each of those
experiences what is the big lesson or
the key takeaway that you've taken with
you that you're bringing now to extend
i would say that uh first of all
obviously like everything else you learn
from from each day that you pass i mean
from every experiences from every
company you build from every
failure that you have you're learning
from it and you're in you're running
forward with a backpack
filled with new types of tool sets and
experiences
and
you know specifically for me
um you know the whole you know the whole
the whole story of my first business at
the age of ten
uh i guess it's it's something in it's
it's something in my in my head right i
was i was born that way i have to
uh create i have to build something all
the time you know i can't just stand in
place
um and that kind of drives me you know
even even today we're we're not a small
company anymore extend is already 50
people 60 people
we always have to create we all have to
uh be be in front of everyone else
trying to innovate
um you know just trying to be the best
as we can in everything that we do and
so what were some of those businesses at
10 years old that you started
so uh my first business at least the
first one that i remember or the one
that my parents remember is uh so my
parents bought me a parakeet at the age
of 10 i was living in a town called
richard lezzion
and i didn't really know to do that it's
a bird inside a cage it doesn't make any
sense it's it's you know it's useless
so what i did is i bought another one
and i started to replicate them uh once
i had like 50 or 60 or 100 i started i
started to sell them all over israel i
remember saturdays my mother was taking
me with a big cage inside the car
basically selling birds birds or across
richard and estiona in tel aviv
and i was making quite a lot of money
that age
very very cool and and take me to when
you were when you broke a satellite well
how does that how does one get get the
opportunity to actually do that
it wasn't on purpose
uh and i'm really sorry it happened but
uh so you know something that that
happens happens in the uh in the israeli
defense forces that you get a lot a lot
of responsibility uh at a very young age
so i was i was an aerospace engineer at
the age of uh 22 23 i had the
opportunity of uh leading a satellite
launch into space
um you know israel israel is a very
unique country it's the only country in
the world that actually sends a
satellite into space in the opposite
direction of the earth it's crazy i mean
the euro spins one way and we don't use
this it's rotation we we send satellite
the other way just because we don't want
to send satellites over iraq and iran so
we send it towards
towards the west towards europe right i
had no idea what yeah they were crazy
that way i guess and and what happened
is that uh
um you know
the booster that sends the satellites
into space has three phases the third
phase failed
and actually that satellite crashed
somewhere near near europe near italy
um i was i was the satellite launch
manager so imagine like this nasa
environment you know with like 200
people
you have to say uh um you know you have
to you have to push the red button and
say uh you know destroy so that was a
very i have a lot of scars from that day
actually
i changed roles they changed jobs
afterwards but uh you know it's it's a
live experience right
and obviously it wasn't my fault so
i can only i can only imagine uh what
what a life experience this has
going back to going back to this idea of
extended reality
we're definitely talking here about
something that we don't see in our day
to day yet we're obviously we're
starting to with extend but this is not
something that is that is entirely
mainstream
can you explain to me a little bit the
rationale that you entered
building this company obviously you're
coming with with background in a lot of
different areas that are relevant to
this but what is sort of the thesis that
you're that you're really understanding
as you're building this out so let me
take you back to the area of 2010 uh i
was working for a uk company called
thales in the in in a city called called
leicester two hours north of london
and one day i was sitting with a friend
of mine a guy called oren in a pub we
were drinking beer obviously you know
the uk after after a hard hard day work
and uh and we saw a game football game i
don't know manchester whatever
we don't remember the teams and and oren
said to me uh wouldn't it be amazing to
see the game from the eyes of the goalie
and i told him
let's do it you know it sounds like a
challenge no one is doing it
let's create a technology that allows
you to see the game from the eyes of the
players players themselves
we took a napkin we wrote down some
ideas some drone ideas some some video
graphics ideas
uh and four year four year later four
years later uh we actually uh
broadcasted in the 51st super bowl in
santa clara uh the game from the eyes of
the quarterback uh live during the super
bowl
um and we even got an emmy award for it
wow so that was like a big tick in the
box you know
like hey oren remember that day in that
pub big tick in the box
holy crap wait i have to understand a
little bit better how does that actually
work what do you mean from the eye of
the quarterback so what we did in
replays we created the technology called
volumetric video we actually allowed uh
we placed study cameras around a venue
and what we did is we actually created
reality using uh 3d video so all the
pixels inside the inside the scene
are made from 3d uh pixels we call them
voxels
and think about it like like a like a
big scanner
so you can actually create a camera
angle from everywhere in the in the
court
wow so why not create a camera angle
from the eyes of the quarterback
right um that was that was the uh that
was the idea it happened
uh we had no idea how to make money out
of it zero zero zero
i mean how can you make money out of
show you know showing a game from the
eyes of the quarterback so we actually
became a vr company very early on um
just because we thought it would be very
cool to put vr on your head and fly
behind messi or
whatever
um and eventually
you know we became the the one of the
best vr companies in in the world
actually creating content for vr and
we sold the company to intel roughly 200
million dollars in 2016. the company is
still running until intel sports
um
so you know this is how we entered to
your question the world of extended
reality you know someone puts vr on
their head and flies into a venue
somewhere in the world
and to that extent we do something
similar just
the only difference is there a machine
at the end there is a drone there is a
car there is a boat you put your vr and
you connect to that machine
and you're actually there you move it
very easily
you hear
you can talk
you can interact with reality
so it's a whole new experience that
allows you to do things uh uh in a whole
new way
and we call it telepresence uh we call
it extended reality we call it a lot in
a lot of work
fancy words at the end of the day it's
it's a very effective way of uh of doing
today for professionals to do very very
you know
such such things that you wouldn't do
that you wouldn't wouldn't want to do
physically
for example soldiers for example a
building inspector it has to fly high
and go inside a building
and so on
and so obviously you know the
applications of this are countless
um it raises questions as well
questions that that we all occupy
ourselves with i know that many
philosophy classes in academia uh occupy
themselves with that
what what are some questions that you're
asking yourself as you're building this
out
whether it's a morals ethics
philosophical
how much does that play out into your
planning because you are literally
pioneering a new way of interacting with
the world which is the integration of
humans and machines in the same
playground and it's not that everybody
is going to transition to machines
together some are going to transitions
earlier than others
and so i think today uh this market this
drone vr robotics market is where the
computers market was in in the 70s
there's no standards there's no
you know there's no windows everything
is dos-like
to those who know doses
and and and i think that uh we are
actually trying to create a standard
we're trying to build an operating
system
that allows uh operators to actually
control remote machines uh we call it
the extend os extend operating system
it's built around a very sophisticated
technology that basically allows you to
do basic things like
go to a waypoint land take off and so on
but there's an additional layer that
actually allows to empower the operator
you know why don't i
um you know pick up something why don't
i fly through a window
a lot of things that you wouldn't be
able to do in any other way unless
you're a very very high
proficient uh drone operator and most
people are not
and this is the first barrier of entry
for this market and we actually solve
solved it so it's it's it's an it's an
amazing uh
it's an amazing uh achievement for us
and and the problem is right now how do
you focus on the right on the right
place on the right market
um
what what are considerations that come
into play as you're deciding which which
segment to actually go and tackle some
of them are are more technologically
difficult some of them are more
lucrative in terms of of business some
of them are easier for adoption how do
you decide
uh so we look at uh we look at you know
obviously market size the time and the
sum
but we look very strongly at regulation
this field uh is very very uh limited by
regulation you cannot fly a drone above
250 grams above people and so on and so
on right so you know regulation is a
very hard
point in in terms of a barrier barrier
for entry
uh we also look at what
makes us uh wake up in the morning right
you know right so you know for example
inspection
boring right i mean why are building a
company around inspection right
right so
today we're creating this uh you know
we call it skylord it's it's it's the
best games in the defense defense market
think about soldiers with vr
fly we fly today at above 150 kilometers
per hour in the sky inside buildings
it's crazy it's uh it's like uh it's
like the the best game you ever played
in your life and we actually used to
save lives so it's fun
that's incredible
yeah so it gets us excited you know you
save human lives uh um you know you you
actually make an impact
uh but but you know what's the next step
what do we do after defense do do we do
something after defense do we build a
defense company only so you know we
decided very early on that extended
extend is uh let's call it uh uh a
holding company that has a a defense
company called skylord and another
company called the telepresence company
we are trying to kind of juggle a few a
few bulls in the air
that's that that's really really cool
now as you're building this company out
and you're obviously creating a culture
on it and you're working on some really
cutting-edge technology
what is the reception of people around
you that are actually starting to use
these products do you find that that
it's becoming a second nature to them is
this something that is easily that is
easy to understand and to actually adopt
as a part of an operation right because
then this is starting to become you know
a default i guess in the mainstream
operations that people will be doing
whether it's for for military purposes
for life-saving purposes what is the
adoption like
so i i'm happy to say that this market
is is quite uh young
to begin with
so
our market education is relatively small
and i can tell you we had a workshop
with uh with uh let's call it customers
in in the us department of defense and
they were like you know we're not
changing our ways when we go to a
building
there's a certain way we go into a
building right there's someone going in
with a gun in front of them two guys
going in the back and so on so they were
very uh
they were not sure this is going to
change their way of their mode of
operation
after two hours obviously all of them
know how to fly like exports it takes
about five minutes
and after the workshop they basically
told us there is no way we're doing it
differently i mean this this is the only
way to go
uh it's not only that we save lives it's
much more effective
this drone can recognize uh you know
cyber right it can it can recognize
um you know things in the building with
thermal imaging it's it's a it's a much
more much more effective way of actually
doing things
very very simple
yeah
and obviously um if we were to do this
episode in in a year or two it would
look different as it looks different
than if we were to do it a year or two
before and and i'm just thankful that i
got to be
to pick your brain in a tiny tiny place
you know in in the middle of this
journey that obviously we'll be looking
back at this in in in like you know 10
15 years and whether it's extend or
whether it's other companies this field
is going to be you know crazy and and
obviously this is the future and and i'm
really excited for where we're headed
and so thank you for taking the time to
share this to share this with me i have
a few more questions for you aviv and i
want to take you back more about
yourself and back to your childhood
obviously starting entrepreneurship at
10 years old what really fascinated you
as a kid as you were going around the
world what was really sparking your
curiosity
so i was i was actually i lived in uh in
in london in the us in israel i was
actually traveling a lot when i was
young and but as as far as i can
remember my childhood i was always i
always loved to build things
um i i love to to you know to take
things apart like like a like a broken
television set and build something out
of it um so i was always
i like to call it i was always a creator
i always always loved to invent things
uh very very cool and and you know back
in the day i invented things which are
more basic
and today it's a bit more sophisticated
you know volumetric video extended
reality
and what inspires you today in your
day-to-day world whether it's you know
the small stuff or whether it's a bigger
idea of where this world is headed
uh basically what inspires me i would
say the most thing is is people um i
love uh taking a group of people and
creating this synergy so all of i had i
had four startups and teams a day all of
them started with people and not with an
idea not with a problem to solve and
these people together
you know we said let's do something
together let's make the world a better
place let's
solve a problem
and i love that uh i know i love the
fact that three four people get together
and one year later they have a company
that actually does something then
actually makes an impact
that's that's amazing for me and as
you're bringing these people together
are you
intentionally you're you're describing a
process that you envision which will be
ideating together trying out things
together and deciding on which company
to build and it's a different group
every time
uh so i was i was i'm working with my
brother in the last three companies out
of four wow um but but i always uh like
to you know i like to to work with
people i i love people i i get along
with you know friends
extend was was started i mean and a
friend good friend of mine idea to be we
were just friends we met at a pub uh
we just said let's think about something
and extend happened so i i love it very
very cool and aviv what are three words
you would use to describe yourself
um
so uh i would say that
i'm a creator
as i mentioned before very very curious
so i'm a curious guy
um
and the third word uh g um
i i wanna say i wanna say uh super you
know i'm super devoted i'm uh if if i if
i
take something i'm not gonna let it go
until it's done you know i don't know if
it's if it's in one word i'll take it
out
i don't know i think it's even more than
passionate it's a i i somebody used a
word recently
um i'll have to think about it and get
back to you but which which described
this idea that that you will just won't
give up until some until until it
happens and and you won't be able to
nudge and i can definitely resonate with
you myself thank you very very much
relentless relentless that is that that
is i think the word yeah i'm relentless
that's a good word
i think that i think that's the word
thank you very very much best of luck
with extend and thank you for the time
bye-bye bye everyone